in the real world we are trapped in our
own bodies contained within our own
appearance now sure we can tweak our
physical shape through diet and exercise
or we can cut and style our hair but
ultimately we have very little control
over how we actually look to other
people not so in the world of video
games though the ability to customize
your character or avatar has long been a
staple of role-playing adventure games
in fact one of the finest creation
engines I've ever used is found in
Dragon Age Inquisition the latest entry
into the fantasy epic series from
Bioware certainly playing with these
creators and crafting the ideal hero is
a lot of fun but why is enjoyable and
perhaps more interestingly why do we
create the characters that we do
[Music]
to find the answers to these questions I
started by asking a few of my lovely
colleagues here at the CBS Interactive
London office to have a blast at making
a character in the Dragon Age
Inquisition editor naturally I filmed
the process so kick back have a watch
and maybe ask yourself if you can see
any similarities between what you do in
character creation and what these guys
said when you've got all of the options
available to you I think I naturally go
towards trying to build me I kind of
always am a character that has essence
of me but then is better than I am
better cheekbones than I am
generally they don't know that they're
not a short or weedy in video game land
so it's kind of like me if I was put
into an automaton machine or something
like that
it's my wife so creating something that
looks a bit like her although sometimes
that goes badly wrong I think sometimes
you sort of fall into the uncanny valley
and it just looks dreadful gonna go full
two-handed warriors I like the idea of
just attacking without defending is the
option to give myself a bum chin because
of the bum bum insider
up to you on your chin to look like I'd
like it to look quite like a bum gels no
I tend to name my characters after war
leaders so yeah so Napoleon Churchill
things like that done basil basil the
destroyer he is ready drew gone I'm
going with drew God
now as some of you might have guessed
one of these people isn't actually a
colleague of mine in fact Mark Wilson is
a reader in psychology at the University
of Middlesex and as long-running reality
check fans will surely remember a
regular expert on the show so I sat down
for a proper chat with Mark to get the
detailed psychology angle on all of this
and also to try and figure out exactly
what's going on inside my weird
colleagues brains a really attractive
idea when we're creating an avatar to
create an ideal version of our own self
so that's something core someone rather
than who is more attractive stronger
more athletic looking one of the
problems with that type of idea is that
if you create someone which is too ideal
too heroic and to godlike then you could
actually lose the sense of immersion
immersion requires it to be some sort of
physical or psychological link between
you and the avatar that you're playing
if that distance is too great then this
is no longer me it's somebody else many
people want to maintain the illusion
that when you play the game this is not
you driving a character this is you and
that's an important distinction because
if you consider your behavior in game to
be your behavior not just some Souls
digital creation then the the plot the
actions and the moral decisions the
emotional effects can be far more real
now when I build characters I don't
usually try to recreate myself in the
game however I have found that I do tend
to include a very few specific
attributes of me in my characters for
example I used to give my avatars curly
hair back when I had that and now I
notice myself frequently creating heroes
with shaved heads so I asked mark if
including specific characteristics of
ourselves in characters perhaps ones we
don't really love could really all be
about trying to validate our own
real-world appearance
one of the things we pretty much know
when we create a game character is that
this this avatar is going to bludgeon
kill or fireball its way through
hundreds or even thousands of opponent
so it's it's a god-like creation now if
we can see a short skinny bald godlike
creation doing that and that's what we
may perceive ourselves as becoming this
is quite a psychologically healthy thing
to do the fact is is that as as physical
entities as physical cells we are
trapped within our bodies we have some
control over them but but really it's
very limited what online worlds allow us
to do is to take complete control over
our appearance and allow our psychology
to drive our behavior what we do tend to
find is the people who are more
comfortable in themselves don't have
such strong preferences for creating
heroic or beautiful avatars similarly
people who score high on the personality
dimension of agreeableness that is
they're they're very easygoing they get
on well with people tend to create
avatars that are less ideal than people
who score low on this personality
tension now as Mark alluded to not
everybody creates a character resembling
themselves in any way and if this
describes you then fear not on next
week's episode I'm gonna do a part two
of the psychology of character creation
focusing on creating different
characters including why as much as 30%
of men choose to play as women and also
have the character you create can
actually have an impact on your own life
and real-world behavior so make sure you
come back next week for that and in the
meantime why not leave me a comment
about this episode in the box down below
or of course you can send me a tweet at
cam for us Rob okay folks thanks for
watching see you next week
you
[Music]